Yumi is a problem The League champion
has been a thorn in Riot's side since
her release she's been called the single
most anti-fun champion in League of
Legends history Riot have desperately
tried to fix her over the years
including some more changes this week
but has it all failed some are saying
the only solution is to do to you me
something that has never been done to a
champion before
all right before we get into the video I
want to remind you that we have a brand
new show out called into the dark we're
making it in partnership with Kraken rum
it's a one-of-a-kind dive into the
incredible stories behind Gaming's
biggest protagonists as they took a leap
into the unknown and emerged Victorious
It's unlike anything we've done before
and the first episode is already out
covering the Amazing Story of simple and
how he overcame toxicity and the
challenges of a new region to become the
goat of Cs go you can check it out using
the link in the description below
alright so I'm sure many of you know you
me already the magical cat that latches
onto an Allied Champion making her
untargetable while she spam supportive
spells it's that untargetable nature
with no Reliance on positioning that has
made her so difficult to balance since
her release a little over four years ago
she simultaneously feels unkillable
while making her allies into absolute
monsters and you can't even deal with
her like most Enchanted is by just
bursting her down because she's
constantly hidden behind another
player's health bar and even in Pro play
fans just found it incredibly boring to
watch a champion like this one which you
didn't even see on the map for most of
the game at one point Riot literally had
to publish an article defending her very
existence to the fans who wanted her
removed from the game it's not just a
meme people have really hated her she
saw an almost constant presence in Pro
play during the first two years of her
release when Riot did try to Nerf her in
2021 they felt they went too far and
then buffed her the following year that
turned out to be a complete disaster at
World 2022 where she ended up with a 95
pick ban rate she only made it through
the band phase in 8 out of 76 of those
games and was on The Winning Side in all
of them in between week one two fans
cheering as Yumi is banned out that
champion medic will not need to tweet
about Yumi at least for the first game
today after worlds riots smashed the cat
again with another Nerf Hammer that left
her effectively dead this time she was
as good as gone from the game and
although there is one way to fix a
broken Champion it's obviously not ideal
and so in March this year Riot launched
a rework for Yumi that sought to balance
her by creating counter play and
limiting her presence in Pro play while
still leaving her as a viable option for
new players to the game Riot frocks on
had already said as much in February by
calling Yumi a great Champion to bring a
friend into the game one that was
supposed to be easy to learn but hard to
master because let's be honest League's
learning curve has steepened a lot over
the years there's so much going on that
a tutorial could simply never cover
having a champion like Yumi does allow
new players to get familiar with league
in what is ostensibly an interactive
spectator mode before having to learn
everything else about the game it does
help ease that learning curve slightly
with that objective in mind Riot swapped
yumi's passive shield and her heel made
her cue more difficult to land and added
a heel to her ultimate but some
immediately said the rework had failed
the riot had not achieved what they set
out to do and the event I think these
changes perhaps made her even stronger
now part of all this is undoubtedly her
crazy Synergy with zerry who has been
dominating the 80 carry meta in recent
months Yumi Shores up her weaknesses and
amplifies her strengths to ridiculous
levels particularly in Pro play as much
as Riot wanted this to finally be the
fix for Yumi even they had to admit it
hadn't quite gone to plan just over a
month after the rework Ryan announced
Yumi would be disabled during the
upcoming MSI 2023 because in their words
her mid-scope isn't quite ready for pro
play yet so rather than risk having an
untuned and disruptive Champion she will
be disabled and so for the first time in
a while fans were treated to a whole
tournament that didn't feature the
untargetable Hellcat making pro games
significantly less exciting to watch I
was lucky enough to watch some of those
games in person at MSI and I have to
admit her presence was not missed in
fact many people felt the removal of
this single champion from the pool made
the entire game more fun to watch but
others also warned she'd be back with a
vengeance once the domestic leagues
returned that disabling her was only a
temporary fix and to be honest that's
kind of what happened Yumi is so far
sitting at a 97.4 presence in the lck
with only a single game in which she's
not been picked or banned the only
Silver Lining there is that she does
have the lowest win rate out of the top
8 most contested Champions but had near
total presence in that league is being
pointed to as a failure of the rework to
curb her power in Pro play and you can
also point to the LPL where although her
presence is only half as much as seen in
the lck she's sitting at an astonishing
73.3 win rate the highest of any
Champion played more than five times in
that league in a heavily downvoted post
Riot freak took to Reddit to defend the
rework as mostly successful showing how
yumi's solo Q win rate and pro play
presents have both dropped after her
rework and also explained her continued
popularity in the lck as being down to
the Region's poor drafting now
personally I think it is a little bit
dismissive to essentially ignore the
lcks data because you don't think they
know what they're doing I'm not saying
they're perfect but let's give them some
credit freak also pointed to yumi's win
rate as a sign that her power had
shifted away from Pro play and towards
the average player but the latest
numbers from this week May put a dent in
that argument on Wednesday Riot released
patched 13.12 which changed her heel and
shield power to now be based on spell
rank instead of Ally level while also
reducing the field value and attack
speed buff on her e and the heel per hit
of her ultimate it's only been two days
but these changes have Yumi currently
sitting at an abysmal
45.26 win rate across all ranks
worldwide the worst of all support
Champions her partner in crime zerry has
also received Nerfs and a hit to her win
rate too which may have had a knock-on
effect on Yumi so she's not looking
great in solo queue at all which
definitely doesn't fit Riot's plan to
keep her viable for the average player
we'll have to wait until the patch is
pro play to see if they have
successfully punctured her presence
there but if they have mission
accomplished kinda one out of two ain't
bad well not really if you ask me she'll
just disappear from the game entirely
again like the last time Riot nerfed her
numbers without actually addressing her
core gameplay and if they then try to
buff those numbers later down the line
to compensate well the cycle will just
continue many feel that Yumi is simply
an unfun Champion with zero skill
Express question one that no amount of
balancing can ever fix but Riot's
hesitant to touch the real issue here
gameplay built around being untargetable
is likely due to the undeniable fact we
talked about earlier in the video that
she's just good for new players and
that's something that bippo a very
outspoken critic of Yumi over the years
put very well on stream recently if I
could have tried Lee by playing Yumi and
sitting on someone in season two and
just getting a feel for the game I
guarantee you I would have started
playing this game way earlier but
because it was such a different
experience I didn't even really know
what was happening or what to do in the
game it made it so much harder to get
into the game for so many people Yumi
circumvented that in a way yumi's genius
for competitive play she is an absolute
cancer and I hate that she exists and I
don't know why they don't disable her
for competitive play and that suggestion
is something I've heard more and more
from a community as the Yumi issue
continues to be a problem keep her in
game for the air average player but out
of bounds for pro play now that may
sound great on paper but it does go
against a core pillar of Riot's Esports
operations that the game you watch Pro
players playing is the exact same one
you can boot up on your PC at home if
you meet is removed from the game in Pro
play that will no longer be true you
will technically be playing a different
game to the pros even if it's just in
that slightest of ways but if Riot can't
balance her and they're unwilling to
change her core gameplay because of her
benefits to new players is that the only
option they have left should they keep
tweaking the numbers or resign you me to
becoming League's tutorial mascot a
champion that is great for getting new
players into a decade old game but one
that is too unfun and too powerful for
pro play riots have likely known these
options for a while but the pressure to
choose one just feels like it's mounting
an interactive spectator mode I did
enjoy writing that yeah and I've
actually never seen anyone else say that
I was writing it I was writing and I was
like it's actually true this it is an
interactive spectator mode yeah that's
what it is